follow your intuition if you want to
have success as an entrepreneur you have
to learn to trust your gut and to listen
to your intuition so you can make
decisions that will help you and serve
you
hi i'm evan carmichael i believe that
hungry entrepreneurs deserve help and
today i'm answering a question from
christina who's one of my newsletter
readers who wrote in long email
basically saying
she quit her job because she was getting
way too stressed out at it she doesn't
know what she wants to do yet as a
business
and wanted my advice on how to sustain
herself financially until she got her
business venture off the ground
hey christina congrats for having the
courage to go out and do that
a lot of people
stick with a job that they hate
only because
it pays the bills
and then as you get more and more into
it it's harder and harder to leave that
job because you get stuck in that
corporate world i'm reminded of steve
jobs who's the founder of apple and he
dropped out of university to drop in on
hanging out with computer geeks who are
building their own computers at home
and at the time people said you're crazy
why would you do that who's going to use
a computer are you kidding me
and we all know a story of steve jobs
and you have to
learn to trust your intuition and trust
your gut
and take steps even though you may not
know how it's going to work out you have
to trust that in the future
the dots will align for you that it will
work out if you're following your heart
so for you this is a great step
now at the same time i'm worried for you
because you don't have anything to fall
back on you have no business idea you
have no job
when you're starting a business
it's an exciting time you want to build
it around something that you are
intensely passionate about
you have to love it
where you are now
i probably wouldn't start the business
yet
because it does take time and you don't
want to be rushing yourself and be
forced
to make money immediately because you're
going to make the wrong decisions you
have to know your market and know your
customers before you really launch a
successful company
so whatever idea you have whatever
business venture you have in mind is if
you're going through a couple ideas
a make sure you're really passionate
about it but then b
instead of starting it right away go
work for a company who's already doing
it go work for a company who you admire
somebody who you want to be in five
years in 10 years
it's going to do two things for you
one
you're going to make money
you're going to alleviate the fear
you're going to have pretty soon of
running out of cash
right you need to survive you got to get
by so go get a job in that field
so you can survive instead of some dead
end crappy job that stresses you out go
find a job that you're gonna like
and learn from the entrepreneur get as
close as you can to them learn what
makes them successful learn how they
started their business learn how to get
new customers
because all that's gonna help you
when you launch your own business you
are getting paid by them
to learn the ins and outs of being an
entrepreneur in that industry you're
going to make all your mistakes
while getting paid by them
it's like going to university for the
ideal job as an entrepreneur
and getting paid to do it at the same
time i'm concerned about you and your
financial needs and i want to make sure
that that's taken care of
you're not going to get rich by going to
work for somebody else
okay but i don't want to see you
not being able to pay your rent
not be able to pay your phone bill
so go get a job from a company who you
respect who you want to be like in five
to ten years
learn the ropes learn what it takes to
be successful in that business and then
start your own company on the side
eventually transition at the full time
and you're on your path to success
good luck you're a woman of courage
so i think you'll do well here for those
of you watching
you like the video please give it a
thumbs up below it makes me want to do
more for you and hey i want to hear what
you have to think if you have other
advice for christina let me know in the
comment section below and if you have a
question for your business please leave
it in the comments below i always read
those when i wake up and i have my
breakfast i'm eating my lentils for
breakfast i love seeing those youtube
comments come in thank you guys you make
my day i'll see you soon